so guys as we know Tristan's message has
been leaked today it has now been
confirmed that he's actually passed it
on to the news reporter honestly the
speed that he does it is absolutely
insane and considering this was over a
week ago it's only been positioned girls
my God
look at these girls they have with them
episode
now he's crazy just watch the footage
sneaky Sly of hand the clip has been
slowed down but if you look closely you
can clearly see Tristan gets very close
to the reporter and his hand gets close
and then he releases the paper
I've screenshotted it before look at the
Garden Andrew's eyes they both look to
see what Tristan has given the reporter
watch them closely
what did he tuck it into God
looks down and then looks back at him
now if you didn't already know
do evidence against us is our friends
made tick tock videos in 2021 that is
why I'm in prison ask
dude's evidence that must be a due cuts
that must maybe that's the name of uh
the prosecutor something like that or
something for the evidence ask the
judges who who's influencing them tell
the world what is happening
this is going to be in museums that is a
dope litter
evidence against us is that our friends
Beatrice and Jasmina made tick tocks
videos in 2021 that's why I'm in prison
asked I caught for the evidence I can't
believe they're still in prison tell the
world what is happening Tristan Tate so
it's clear Tristan wanted to get this
news reporter to spread the message even
more quite a powerful message in my
opinion and Tristan pulled it off so
fast as they're constantly moving guys
what are your thoughts on this make sure
you comment Down Below in the comment
section as always please leave a like
subscribe and turn on notifications on
that's so [__] up it makes me I hate
watching this because it genuinely makes
me sad to see that they're still stuck
in prison like what like him or not it
doesn't matter unbelievable it's
actually unbelievable that they're still
locked up for this this nonsense yeah I
don't know how it makes me want to learn
a lot more about Romanian criminal law
and understand how the Romanian people
accept that from their government that
you can just be locked up for a 30-day
increments while evidence is being while
you're being investigated while evidence
is being put together before you've even
been charged I mean this is when people
people complain about America and and
say that it's it's a terrible place to
be like go over there go over there
because at least here in America they
have to present evidence to a judge in
order to charge you yeah before you can
before yeah there's the show where
you're locked up indefinitely God Bless
America because it is it is totally
imperfect but it is as close to perfect
as this world has we can continue to
improve but we need to be a beacon of
light for the world instead of the
people who instead we've got half the
country it is interesting snuff us out
snuff out that we are it is interesting
because there's a lot of like [__]
on America and whatnot but it's also
like where are you gonna go you know
like where else are you gonna go Western
Europe sucks that's that's you know
their their economies are all crashing
you know it's like socially it's just as
bad go to Canada that's the thing about
it the door swings both ways honey you
can come in and you can leave yeah well
Canada that's I mean look what they did
with covet they were they were that was
actually absurd Mexico Canada Mexico
sucks Canada froze accounts of people
who supported the freedom truckers yeah
I mean that's like they froze your bank
personal bank accounts because they
didn't agree with with people supporting
a cause in Eastern Europe is nearly a
war zone at this point I mean Eastern
Europe look what's happening to take
like I mean where do you even go at this
point it's it's Madness so it's like
they're all just closing in on like Mass
control which is the crazy thing because
even the US with covid that was like
obviously just a sign of like how much
they could control us it was just a big
test at the end of the day and um they
showed that the the slave minds they
they bought it they bought it you bought
that [__] too you remember you were like
you got to stay in the house because you
know I didn't know I I I and I still and
I don't regret behaving myself for
during the first two weeks of the three
weeks to flatten the curve and then
right I have no problem I have no
problem admin that I I laid low we
stayed in the house we lasted about two
two and a half weeks and then you broke
first and then I broke and I was like
whatever open the door we're having
company I don't give a [__] anymore
because the curve because it's just the
evidence wasn't there you know the curve
was flattened and then they just kept
they did then they just kept on pushing
us and that story kept changing and I'm
not even gonna lie covet was like a
blessing though like having it um like
being locked in your house as um as
someone in like I was a junior in high
school and it gave you time to like
really like dig into entrepreneurship
and like that was when I was still
pursuing professional gaming and I just
like you you had all the Time in the
World to do whatever you wanted so it
was like people either took advantage of
that and like made genuine careers and
like built their lives out of covid or
they just wasted it and they just jerked
off and did nothing yeah absolutely
right and there's a blessing for people
that took advantage of it but there's
tons of people that took complete
advantage of it like so many people like
Aiden Ross took it full advantage of it
I mean they're like I don't need to go
and list all the names like a lot of of
the biggest creators now took advantage
of covid that's how they got big which
is crazy well that's the thing people
that are good I didn't see it people
that are going to succeed will succeed
no matter what the circumstance is I
mean no matter what's against them and
they don't make excuses we're partnering
up with a Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom
Shea hosts a 21-day virtual event that
you guys can join with us Tom is going
to teach you how to listen to your mind
in a new way and how to control it so
that you can have the discipline you
need to build the life you want so I've
seen this process done for 30 years when
you make it through you will be a
different human being the process is
simple but not easy because of the war
that's inside of us the few people have
been taught to fight overcoming your
excuses so if you're interested in
becoming a reformed human an absolute
animal go to tomshay.com and use Sunny
fast50 for 50 off of this program you
will not regret it you will be a changed
person at the end of it do not miss this
I can't believe they expected us to do
virtual school during covid well like
they expected us to sit on our desk for
eight hours a day five days a week and
um Stan zooms I didn't do that I think
that if it had to be done again even if
school had to be virtual they would do
it differently they would make different
choices but they were doing the best
that they could they were really yeah
everybody everybody was put in a really
bad situation I know I know they're not
part of the Illuminati if you see how it
wasn't but um it was um it was
definitely I mean I would sleep through
all the classes if I'm just being honest
yeah I know I was there
because my sleep schedule was so was so
wrecked I was up till five in the
morning and then I would have to wake up
in two and a half hours for school and I
would just roll over
just paused paused it just hit pause for
a year everybody's gonna be a year and
everyone was like these children are
falling behind and all this like you
know what so if they graduate high
school at 19 instead of 18 is this
really going to send off the world order
like calm down I think that's what
should have been done uh I don't know I
don't know y'all could have just hung
out I could have just hung out yeah I
don't know if we should have just shut
everything down for a year I'm just
saying if it had to be a year or however
long it had to be it could have just
been a delay it should have just been a
delay because what happened is now you
got kids getting a half-assed education
and then now they're pushing kids out
they're writing their sign into poems
for kids that haven't earned their
diploma and that's a real problem yeah
but whatever sounds familiar that's why
that's right we got people watching Tick
Tock people doing nothing on Tick Tock
and getting famous the enslaved men of
our brains thank you guys so much for
watching how do we get there I don't
know whatever thanks guys for watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram and join my Discord
home oh my God there's a big [__]
crack in the first shot I'd rather
riding on the wall won't last long yeah
the feelings
[Music]